[Applaudissements]
il est 16h30 gare montparnasse à paris
voilà ma ram qui arrive david s'apprête
à rendre service sur ce train à grande
vitesse à destination de bordeaux
entré à la sncf en tant que contrôleur
il ya près de 30 ans il est très fier
même parcours
il ya pas mal de choses qui ont changé
ils ont évolué autant le métier que les
outils il est aujourd'hui conducteur tgv
un fleuron des technologies français on
se sent fier est à la fois un peu de
stress parce que à 320 kilomètres heure
il faut que les gestes soient assez
précis et rapide et il faut les
connaître
et puis je mets un point d'honneur à
arriver à l'heure luc david aime
beaucoup son travail
mais depuis quelque temps l'avenir le
préoccupe cinq types inquiétant parce
que on parle encore du chemin pour
l'instant mais plus tard je pense qu'on
parlera plus que le nuage à l'horizon si
le projet de réforme que vient de lancer
le gouvernement alors que la sncf à plus
de 85 milliards de dollars de dette soit
près de 1300 $ par habitant
l'état a décidé de rationaliser
le monde change la sncf doit changer
aussi face à ses concurrents la ss la
sncf ne peut rester la seule à recruter
au statut le statut c'est celui de
cheminots un titre que porte
cent trente mille employés de la sncf
conducteurs contrôleurs et aiguilleurs
signaleurs et techniciens d'entretien et
qui leur confère une série davantage
hors salaires comme la garantie d'un
emploi à vie des billets gratuits et le
droit de prendre sa retraite beaucoup
plus tôt que les autres employés du
secteur public
un train de six ans quatre tonnes une
série de privilèges qui remonte au début
du siècle
741 paix qui effectue ici ces essais
l'état voit des fournisseurs comme des
outils stratégiques
dès les débuts du chemin de fer il y a
eu des politiques spéciales qui
consistait à pour fidéliser le personnel
et pour drainer les personnels les plus
compétents qui a consisté à leur donner
un certain nombre davantage et l'a
soutenu la vitesse de 100 km heure des
avantages liés aussi au caractère
pénible du travail des cheminots
c'est vrai qu'être un mécanicien et un
chauffeur sur les vieilles locomotives
c'était être exposées aux intempéries
c'était un travail physique eux mettre
les pelletées de charbon dans la
chaudière qui était pénible en effet les
temps ont bien changé les traits sont
aujourd'hui électrique
ils circulent à plus de 300 km heure et
les aiguillages sont informatisées je
suis conscient que les métiers qui sont
plus pénibles que les autres luther vide
considère que son métier reste tout de
même pénible
ne serait ce qu'en raison des horaires
décalés et des week-ends travail et je
sens à l'âge actuel où j'ai 52 ans je
suis fatigué tous les deux jours je suis
en découché donc est ce que c'est ça la
pénibilité ne pas pouvoir se reposer
sereinement et d'avoir des repas fixe je
sais pas mais je pense que ça joue
énormément grâce à son statut de
cheminots conducteurs
il aura le droit s'ils le souhaitent de
prendre sa retraite dès l'automne
à 52 ans
une possibilité que perdre les nouveaux
embauchés avec la réforme proposée dans
les faits une réforme précédente a déjà
sérieusement changé la donne
cette douce emma fort francky d'orvin
par exemple qui est cheminot depuis 12
ans devra sans doute travailler encore
trente ans pour obtenir sa pleine
retraite je ne pourrais pas partir à 65
ans parce que d'elle très grosse décote
à 55 ans et puis aujourd'hui on nous
demande minimum quarante deux ans de
cotisation je suis encore très très loin
francky est un agent de signalisation un
métier qu'il adorerait même si le
considère lui aussi pénible car il doit
souvent travaillé la nuit
il inquiète de plus dans le projet de
réforme la sncf c'est l'ouverture à la
concurrence telle que prévue par l'union
européenne on se demande qu'est ce qu'on
va devenir
qu'est ce que c'est exactement
l'ouverture à la concurrence dans
quelles circonstances
dans quel domaine il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations moi aujourd'hui voilà
ces jeux comme beaucoup de mes collègues
je me pose des questions et je sais pas
où ça va nous mener je sais qu'il faut
un changement on a vu qu'il y avait
certains problèmes financiers le
changement est nécessaire mais la façon
dont c'est fait
c'est un peu dommage pour se faire
entendre
les cheminots ont pris les grands moyens
une série de grèves à raison de 2 ou 5
pour les trois prochains mois
le bras de fer avec le gouvernement est
engagé la bataille pour l'opinion
publique vient de commencer